bonjour avoue stanislas godon merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors que depuis le début du
confinement la situation elle semblait
relativement calme elle ce temps on le
voit dans les banlieues pourquoi cet
embrasement dans ces quartiers alors en
fait il faut savoir que dès le début du
confinement
nous avions déjà ressenti des tensions
notamment parce que les individus
auxquels nous avons affaire n'aimez pas
la police n'aimait pas que la police
fasse son travail et n'aimait pas que la
police perturbent notamment les trafics
de stupéfiants qui avait lieu dans ces
quartiers sensibles je rappelle c'est
encore une minorité qui vient à
l'affrontement envers les forces de
sécurité et dès le mois de mars nous
avions assisté notamment à des
guet-apens à des embuscades je pense à
saint denis dans notamment la cité des
francs moisins je pense également à
creil dans val d'oise
donc il faut bien rappeler une chose
c'est que là nous assistons à un
embrasement mais il y avait déjà une
émergence il y avait déjà des signes
avant-coureurs et c'est bien pour ça que
hier vous nous avons écrit une lettre
ouverte et nous avons interpellé
notamment les ministres le ministre de
l'intérieur la garde des sceaux afin qu'
il y ait des mesures qui soient prises
qui est un certain courage politique qui
soit fait pour que notamment on prenne
des sanctions exemplaires à l'encontre
de cette minorité d'individus je le
rappelle qui sèment le chaos qui
s'attaque aux policiers et qui parce que
j'entends certains qui parlent d'
inégalités mais je crois qu'on est tous
égaux face à la loi et que l'on doit
tous respecter à la fois les règles de
la république est à la fois respecter
les règles de confinement qui sont un
enjeu sanitaire majeure vous pensé pour
pour tenter d'expliquer ce qui se passe
est actuellement dans ces banlieues vous
pensez que c'est lié vous
oh cette période de confinement qu'il
n'est pas forcément eu facile dans
certains quartiers alors évidemment que
les périodes de confinement posé un
problème pour cette minorité je le
rappelle puisque ils ne respectent pas
les règles du confinement puisqu'il ne
respectait pas déjà des règles de la
république
donc quand on fait des rodéos motorisés
à 23 heures le soir quand on se regroupe
à 10 15 ou 20 personnes
quand on continue notamment de vendre de
la drogue quand on peut quand il ya des
personnes qui peuvent se rendre dans ces
quartiers et bien effectivement on se
met en écart de la loi et effectivement
la police doit faire son travail
maintenant ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué pour mes collègues puisque ils
ont face à eux des individus qui
n'hésite pas à utiliser des mortiers des
engins incendiaires qui peuvent faire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de dégâts et
heureusement ces derniers jours nous
n'avons pas de policiers blessés
mais je rappelle que tout au long de
l'année ce sont pas moins de vingt
blessés par jour dans les rangs des
policiers lorsqu'ils sont en mission
dans le contexte que vous décrivez est
ce que selon vous les le dispositif
justement est mis en place dans ces
quartiers des suffisant au niveau des
effectifs
écoutez les effectifs ne sont pas
extensibles
je rappelle que l'ensemble des forces
notamment au sein de la police nationale
sont employés à la fois aux missions du
quotidien mais surtout aux contrôles
notamment des règles de confinement il
ya eu pas de moins de 13 millions de
contrôles qui ont été effectués sur le
territoire national mais il faut pas
oublier qu'il ya toutes les autres
missions le terrorisme est toujours
présent il lutte aussi notamment pour
les règles qui sont je dirais de rang
qualité public aussi et je crois que
l'ensemble de ces missions qui sont
dévouées dédié à la police nationale eh
bien il faut saluer encore une fois la
disponibilité de mes collègues qui je le
rappelle sont aussi frappés d'ailleurs
par le cockpit 19
nous avons des collègues dans nos rangs
qui sont testés positifs nous déplorons
toujours d'ailleurs qu'il ne soit pas
dotée de matériel suffisant au niveau de
la protection
nous déplorons aussi que la doctrine du
port du masque pour les policiers qui
sont exposés au contact du public ne
soit toujours pas modifié à cette heure
vous parlais tout à l'heure des
autorités pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
réaction officielle notamment aucune
réaction
sorti en tout cas de christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur à propos de
ce qui se passe actuellement dans ces
quartiers et comment est ce qu'on fait
pour arrêter ces tensions alors ben mes
collègues sur le terrain font ce qu'ils
peuvent avec les moyens qu'ils ont pour
notamment rétablir l'ordre public
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des consignes
pour notamment ne pas procéder à des
contrôles de confinement quand il y à
des risques d'émeutes avéré comme ces
derniers jours notamment
mais il faudra à un moment ou un autre
qu'il y ait un certain courage politique
pour que la reconquête républicaine dont
beaucoup de personnes personnalités
politiques parlent soit quand même mise
en oeuvre mais ça ne peut se faire que
avec un partenariat une combinaison une
chaîne pénale entre les policiers et la
justice trop de fois nous avons eu des
exemples de policiers qui ont procédé à
des interpellations qu'ont mis à
disposition de la justice et qui ont eu
en retour des rappels à la loi des
peines alternatives
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les chiffres
entre 2005 et 2010 9
on s'aperçoit que les peines
alternatives ont pris le pas sur la
prison ferme et notamment en ce qui
concerne les attaques envers mes
collègues sur le terrain
merci beaucoup stanislas godon d'avoir
réagi en direct sur rt frangins telles
que êtes le délégué général du syndicat
alliance police nationale